So you, so you, um, are you idiot, but it's all good.
So, but so you do so you have your, you, but you also,
this is something that cause like, I feel like you're like,
you feel bad about, um,
like you feel deeply bad. So this is something I admire about you. Sorry,
what? Sorry. Oh,
about the zipper you feel deeply bad about her hurting people's feelings.
Like deeply. I feel like you're like hyper feel badly about them. Yeah.
That's true. Yeah. I'm very, yeah. I'm very empathic. Whether I like it or not.
Am I like that? Absolutely not. Yeah, no, I got all that. I got all that.
So I didn't start at the OCD. Yeah. You know what, actually,
this is interesting. I actually wanted, this is,
this is the one thing I wanted to talk about. Really? Yeah.
Cause it's Christmas. Yeah. It's a scary world out there.
We're all going to see our families.
That can be very dreadful and it can be scary. And you know,
if you're like me very empathic, you're even feeling bad.
Even if you feel good and then somebody comes up and they're in a bad mood,
you're like, Oh.
Now.
Yeah. And then you feel bad because someone else felt bad.
That's not a good way to live your life. Right.
So I have a lot of experience with feeling really bad. Right. Okay.
So, so I have a lot of experience feeling really bad.
I figured out how to never feel bad. Oh, do you know? Nope.
But I think you're wrong already. Now.
I think you might even agree to be honest. Okay. This is like some real.
This is real. This is it's real. Okay. So,
uh,
one thing you can tell about something that's going to be real is if somebody
says this is real. No, I, I S I S I preface it like that because I know. Okay.
When the right one, I say it, people are going to think I'm not serious. Okay.
Like, imagine the, I mean, that's my whole life,
the first guy that was like rubbed two woods together and it's fire. Well,
you could just demonstrate that you say that. And the guy's like, no, you can't.
And the guy does it. Well, I mean, they're not talking because you're like,
[inaudible] okay. So, but it's like the first guy that was like, um,
when you come in a girl that makes a baby, well, no,
you can just demonstrate that to someone. I was like, this guy died, you know,
the G like the Christianity, you'd be like, you're crazy guy. Right. So,
but then some people now look around the world, Hey man, look around the world.
Right. A lot of churches. Right. Somebody believed it. Right.
And so it must've worked for somebody. Right. Okay. I'm not religious.
It's not why I bring that should start a church. I do. Well. Yeah. And it,
this could be its foundational tenant. Okay. This is real. Okay.
This is for anytime. You're going to feel, you might feel bad.
Someone makes you feel bad all throughout every day. It's bad.
You look at the news, bad. You think about your feelings batshit.
You think about what people think of you. Bad. Only bad.
Always only all the time. Bad. Right. Sometimes it's like, okay. Right.
Rarely is it great? I can make it if you're coming. Right. You know,
that's rare though.
It's like seven seconds of coming versus 23 hours and
59 minutes of non 47 seconds. That's a good amount.
And I wasn't even right. Actually, we got it right now. Okay. And anyway, so,
okay. It's actually you, so in any situation like this, it's,
it's sort of like all purpose, right? You let's do it as an example first,
but I'm wondering if it's taking you to guide them along to say,
that's part of how do you make, how you make sure people know you're see.
That's true. That's true. That's true. I guess that's a good point.
You ever listened to anybody? NPR serious talk. Yeah.
This is how it goes to the NPR. It was the 33 minutes before they make a point.
So true. Right. Is it true that monkeys? You know what I mean? And you're like,
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can take a break in the middle and just pick back up at the end,
but you can't do that now. Cause all that matters. Okay.
So say something that I won't like. Okay. But hold on, you have to say,
I have to actually have to know I'm not going to like it.
So hold on before you do it because you know me very well.
You can say something about me that, you know,
I won't like it has to be something, you know,
I won't like in real life or just make, got to say something.
It doesn't have to be about. Yeah, I got you.
I don't mind me if something I don't like whatever. So hold on. I'm going to,
I'm going to, you're going to say it.
I'm going to say the way you respond and then no matter what it is,
you don't feel bad anymore. You're going to say, okay. That's it. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. Doesn't it suck that everyone, you know, is going to be dead.
It can't be questioned. Oh, okay. Hey, everyone, you know,
is going to be dead one day. Okay.
So yeah. Okay. That was a terrible thing to say. Yeah.
Every, every person I've ever known yeah.
Is gonna die. Yeah.
K or you just say K K Y K. Like, okay.
Yeah. But no, it's not. I mean, yeah,
but that's the word you're you're you're you're not just saying. Okay.
I'm like poaching from that area of words. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
But here's the thing you could say it in a different way to right.
Say something like, all right. Okay. So I got one. So, uh, yeah, the, um,
it sucks. Uh, my, my house was in the Malibu fires and a burndown.
Yeah. That's uh, I mean, I would, I love that. Oh, okay.
I love that too. For two. Now here's the thing that, for real though,
you could do it about anything, your,
your Christmas and then your mom is like needling you.
How come you don't. Yeah. You don't have a girl. And I think that it's getting,
you're getting, it's getting,
you're getting too old and you're not going to be able to be a good dad.
You're going to be too old to be a debt. Okay. Fair enough. Right.
Like you could say it, right. You could say other words with Kay. Okay.
But then the mom might be like, what do you mean? No, you don't.
It's not for her. Say the moms. So you feel better when you do those. Yeah.
I guess about other people. I get it. Who can do that's the whole point.
K not. Okay. Right. Okay. So that's the thing, right?
I used to brewed all day, dude. Yeah. This is serious. Talk to anybody. I know.
one fire knows anybody in my life that knows me. Well,
enough is in my life for the last eight months. Knows what happened. Yeah.
And that's what happened. Okay. Yeah. I elaborately liked that. Yeah.
It'll work. Honestly. Everyone's going to be like either.
Ha what did he talk about? Just honestly, please try it. Please try it.
You're never going to be with your family. Anyway.
You're going to go watch a tweets now about it.
I'd probably do some videos and I will, I will say it's probably has something.
It's probably like the Darren Brown thing. No. Yeah. Well it could be,
you're interrupting something.
That's very like a handshake and you just go and they're like, what?
And they fall asleep to your own brain though.
You can surprise yourself if you do it enough,
you bury it in the cerebellum part of the brain. I'm a scientist.
I'm a scientist. I know. Okay. So you bury it in the cerebellum,
so it's just automatic. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Right, right, right, right,
right, right. So it's sort of like it's freeing it's.
It is Def it definitely is free. It's going to put meditation out of business.
Okay. Yeah. Wow. Because you don't need it anymore. I agree.
Does the same thing do the same thing. It might not do it as well,
but maybe if you get, maybe if you get a sort of like on a roll with it,
it could, it could be the kind of a thing, like the church of K, right? Yeah,
exactly. I just think people need to do it and learn.
It's not like you can really explain it. I showed you all,
but it's not the same until you really do.
I think that we should do that. I'm going to start doing that. Yeah. I know.
You've been saying KLM and text chains and stuff like that. It's yeah.
I'm really I'm evangelizing that's Angeles. Cool. That's very cool.
That's it's very cocky to do it that way, by the way. But sometimes got,
somebody was like, Oh, my mom just died. Okay. Yeah. That's so rude,
but it's free, but it is free. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
But also if you're going to get into like, somebody's with you. Yeah.
But you want to book. Yeah. Yeah. Hey.
Yeah. Not going to happen. Right. Right. Okay. That is true.
You know what Darren Brown was saying at one time he was going to get in a fight
and the guy said, I, um, he's the guy was like, do you want to fight?
And he said something like, uh, yeah. I think the wall around my house is,
is about four feet tall, but it might be, it might not be, I saw him say that.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm very similar to Denver. Yeah. Well, yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Sure. Okay. Yeah. How do you feel?
Uh, Oh yeah. I feel good because you know, maybe I didn't agree with you even.
I just said K, it was freeing. It was a freeing thing for you, man. I wow.
It doesn't matter if I even hear it. Wow dude. And, but,
so then how do you feel about how we look nice
segue,
but because I'm looking at the monitor and I think I look like pretty like good
in this. And I think that you maybe look like, uh,
like the hair like me, but I did heroin for a long time. Yeah. I think, I,
I think I agree with that. When you look healthy, it looks like you do heroin,
but also eat fruit. K. There you go. Yeah. Wow. Feel good? Yeah.
So would make me mad if somebody kept doing it,
maybe you have to do it sparingly or no. Or it's just for you. You do it quiet.
It makes me less, a little less mad. If the microphone wasn't here,
you wouldn't even, I know it'd be for you. So you could do it under your breath.